Thanks to multiple efforts we have today a more diverse university than ever
Today it is necessary to assimilate that life is changing and that great changes
imply great shocks The university brings a very great purpose and responsibility
with Colombia a country where trans and non-binary people We are demanding a
comprehensive trans law that allows us to guarantee the right to sign our own
identity freely so that the Chuchú of the identity card for the following purposes
can run out that the police do not make arbitrary arrests against us to stop
criminalizing sex work so that sexual and endocrinological health services are
provided in a timely manner and so that our trans older adults have access to
a profession to live their old age with dignity.
The country requires the leadership of people
like us to strengthen institutions,
defend democracy and generate equity.
Is it our task to think about how we can ensure that more people
in Colombia have access to an education with the quality we receive?